hello my name is eberhard kuhn i am the
marketing manager for food and consumer
products
at shimatsu scientific instruments
and in this talk i will be talking about
food aroma and a way of identifying the
chemistry of smell
so
the most sensitive detector in the world
now
we all have one smack in the middle of
our face and
it's our nose right our nose is very
sensitive to detecting the the smell and
the aroma of food which is one of the
pleasures of
of eating if you will
uh unfortunately though the the nose is
not not calibrated and not very
objective so
when it comes to a more objective and
quantitative approach to
measuring and quantitating the
chemistry of smell we turn to science in
particular to chromatography whether
that's liquid chromatography or gas
chromatography with or without a mass
spec so that's what i will be covering
today
the first example will be about coffee
aroma so we'll start the day with our
coffee and
because we're talking about aroma so
those are
volatile compounds so we use gas
chromatography and we use in particular
gcms with the the gc coupled with the
mass spec is really the the ideal
analytical instrument for these volatile
compounds
in terms of the sampling method we're
going to use a solid phase micro
extraction speed me and then we'll
couple that with a headspace inlet so to
really as a good way of sampling those
food aromas
in fact we're going to take it up a step
and instead of conventional speed me
we're going to use this be me arrow
which allows us then to increase the
sensitivity of this method
here you see some examples of the
conventional speed me as well as the
speed me arrow
main difference being the the face
volume
and as you can imagine the amount of
material that can be absorbed is
proportional to the phase volume so if
you look at the conventional speed me
fiber you're looking at 0.6 microliter
phase volume
on this beamy arrow it could be
depending on the diameter of the of the
fiber
up to 12 microliter so that's 20 times
more
phase volume so we have a much larger
absorption phase volume and that allows
you to
collect more material which then
enhances your sensitivity
and that's exactly what we see so here
we're looking at a chromatogram now of
typical
aroma compounds in coffee
bottom chromatogram being the
conventional spami
the top chromatogram being the speedy
arrow and you can see very easily just
looking at the size of the peaks that
this beamy arrow gives us a much better
sensitivity
and it's even easier to see in this
graph here where in
the blue bars or this beamy arrow the
orange bars are the conventionals be me
and the
bars have been normalized to this beamy
arrow so those are always one and so
these are typical aroma compounds that
you will find in coffee
and as you can see this beamy arrow
gives anywhere from three to about ten
fold
increase in sensitivity of the speedy
era over the conventional steamy
okay so now that we've had our coffee we
can start thinking about lunch and we
start cooking our lunch
as we all know if you ever walked into a
kitchen there the the food changes uh
smell as you start cooking it
and that is the result of the the mayo
reaction and that's basically a reaction
between the
amino acids in the proteins in the food
and the reducing sugars and that gives
sort of these characteristic
smell of cooked food
in this particular experiment we are
comparing
unheated and cooked soy sauce
and you see on the right hand side this
um contraption that we built and it's a
enclosed uh
vessel and inside is a mono trap solvent
which is a monolithic
silica adsorbent that will then absorb
those
volatile aroma compounds and if you look
closely you'll see that there is a
shield or a guard around that uh solvent
disc to protect it from uh soy sauce
splashing up because there's you know
little uh milliliter uh milliliter or so
of soy sauce on the bottom of this
heating uh device and we don't want any
splashes to go straight onto the solvent
disc but we only want to trap the aroma
compounds that are released
but once the
that's heated up the aroma compounds are
released then we'll do a simple solvent
extraction of the the mono trap
and when we do that we see immediately
the big differences between the the
unheated and then the cooked soy sauce
so
the pink is the unheated and the black
is the heated and you immediately see
the differences some compounds will be
reduced like peaks number eight and 10
for instance and then other com
compounds are increased like peaks
31
and 35 and we'll see on the next slides
what these are
so
there are uh
compounds that are distinctive for the
cooked soy sauce and there are
different categories there's alcohols as
you can see there's aldehydes there's
the pyroxenes and then and then some
others
and then there's also aroma compounds
that are very distinctive for the
unheated soy sauce those are on the top
right
so those are the compounds that we would
associate with just smelling soy sauce
in a bottle versus smelling soy sauce on
fried rice or fried noodles or things
like this and then on the bottom right
are compounds that are common to both
heated and unheated soy sauce and
because
even heated or unheated we can still
recognize uh soy sauce the smell the
aroma of soy sauce so there are
compounds that are common to both
and we have those summarized here so
the main compounds of the unheated soils
are so all these
butanol and butanol type compounds so
butanol isobutanol
three methyl one butanol so that's what
we
that's what we smell when we smell just
soy sauce as you have it here say as a
dipping sauce for dumplings or or
sushi or so
then once we cook it then we get these
uh reaction products of the mayor
reaction the fulfill alcohol fulfilled
pyrrole pyrozines those kind of
compounds and those we know we associate
them with uh cooked soy sauce like we
have here like fried rice or kampao
chicken or any of those foods that have
cooked soy sauce in them
and so
the results didn't really say that hey
the character of the soy sauce changes
as we start heating it so the character
of soy sauce decreases and we're
creating these fragrant smells
as a result of the of the cooking
so we know that
okay now that we've had coffee and lunch
it's time to think about happy hour and
here we're looking at uh
lemon flavored alcoholic beverages like
uh you know like a lemon like a lemon
vodka or something like that
so those
samples were stored in the refrigerator
prior to opening once we opened them we
put them in a vial with our trusty mono
trap solvent that we've used for these
previous experiments
and then we start heating it up and we
we trap the fragrance components uh in
the uh
monosome and trap and then we'll do a
solvent extraction and again analyze by
gcms
and here's what we'll see so there's
these are the four different uh
lemon flavored alcoholic beverages and
you can see that there's a lot of common
peaks especially at the beginning of the
chromatogram but there are also uh
differences and some of the differences
are you know the the monoterpenes that
we see there like limonene mercene
there are sesame terpenes that we find
like the caryophyllene
uh terpenoids monoterpene alcohols uh
like linolol
and then charanil acetate so a lot of
different uh these kind of flavor
compounds have been identified in some
but not all and especially the aliphatic
aldehydes and we'll see on the next
slide
specifically what these are and i don't
need to go through all of them but you
can see that some of them are very
characteristic of some of the beverages
while others are not in on the
on the column on the right you can see
uh the different
classes of compounds that they're in
but then we uh we went a step further
and we did our principle principle
component analysis pca
and we really see the distinct
differences between all four of those
beverages and you see the colored circle
correspond to the colors of the
chromatogram a couple of slides ago
and you can see that each of the
beverages the
the compounds fall within distinct
clusters and and that can be used in in
the product development i mean
ultimately ultimately the the sensory
testing like this this woman here you
know sampling
the beverage
that's what's important how we perceive
it our sensory perception but
as
the companies develop these products you
know gcms can be used to
cooperate those sensory testing results
and really help i help identify and
categorize and provide a
objective measurement throughout the
product development process to make sure
that there is a consistent product
quality in in the end
okay so
um
sulfur compounds
so as i mentioned on the first slide
our
nose is a very sensitive detector and
especially when it comes to sulfur
compounds and
we often associate sulfur compounds with
unpleasant smell you know like the
typical rotten egg smell that that's uh
so famous for sulphur compounds
but we also saw in this in the um coffee
and we'll see here in the following
slides that there are also sulfur
compounds that contribute positively to
the aroma and the smell of a food
but again our nose is very sensitive to
these sulfur compounds and sometimes the
the gcms is not sensitive enough to pick
those up so we'll have to go to a more
dedicated detector and in this case
we'll be using a sulfur
chemiluminescence detector and scd that
really offers excellent
sensitivity for sulfur compounds even at
low trace levels
and on the bottom right you'll see our
little setup so we're using kimchi as
our sample that's the
famous korean pickled cabbage and it's
in a sealed bag in this little container
and we have our mono trap there again so
as we're heating this up we're trapping
these uh
kimchi flavors and then we'll do
a solvent extraction again
and so what we'll see then is we'll have
this dual uh detector approach on the
bottom you have the gcms a total ion
chromatogram
on the top you have the gcse the sulfur
chemical luminescent detector and you
can see much bigger peak so it's much
easier to quantify these sulfur
compounds with an sed than with the mass
spec in particular if you look at peaks
four or five now you have to look very
closely to find them in the mass back
trace versus the sed where they're very
prominent so
with the sed a dedicated sulfur detector
you'll pick those up
keep in mind though that that detector
is specific for the sulfur compound so
if you look at the chromatogram there
are a couple of large peaks that are
between four and six minutes
those peaks must not contain sulfur ions
because you don't
see them in the in the scd chromatogram
so
anything that's not sulfur related of
course is lost within with an sct
chromatogram
so i remember we took it to the next
step and this is something that i'm sure
you've all experienced if you have
a food in a in a tupperware type of
container you can not only stain but
some of the the food smell will remain
behind so we actually did the experiment
here so we we took the the kimchi
container we washed it with water and
then we cut it into little pieces put
the little pieces in the little uh jar
and uh heated it up and we captured
whatever
was released all the molecules with a
speedy fiber in this case when we
weren't using the monitor we're actually
using a multi-phase speed me that was a
dvd divinely benzene carbon and td ms
polydimethyl cyloxane so this multi-mode
speed me will capture the sulfur that's
released from the
pieces of the container to see what is
what is left behind even after rinsing
with water
so again we're comparing the the scd
with the gcms and in this case we broke
the chromatogram which is about 30 some
minutes long into three
sections and and you can see here on the
the first segments again you see
immediately like peaks four uh much
greater sensitivity on the
on the sed compared to the uh to the
gcms
and then here again this is the middle
section and you can see some of the
peaks that are getting much more
pronounced like peak
19 or 22 in particular is much greater
on the uh
on the sad than it is on on the gcms
and here is the the tail end of the
chromatogram and you can see a lot of
these compounds 29
32
those are all much much
more pronounced on the
sulfur chemical menescence detector
compared to the
to the mass
spec so again it just shows that
the mass that the um
we'll go to the here's just the uh the
this all the different compounds if you
wanted to look at what all of these 36
compounds were
but here again a total of 36 we saw and
in but were identified in the wash
kimchi container and you can see here on
the top on the left is the
scd trace on the right is the gcms and
you can see that
because the scd only looks at sulfur
compounds there's no interference like
you would have on the mass spec so you
have some interference there that may or
may not give you as accurate a
quantitation of those sulfur compounds
and the same you see on the bottom you
get a
a simpler chromatogram if you will with
the scd because it is very selective and
because of that it's also very sensitive
and so it's an excellent choice for
trace sulfur compound analysis
and now for something completely
different
brought to you by the ministry of silly
walks
so
some foods
you don't
smell until you actually
bite into them for instance on the
bottom right you see this this woman
smelling the apple in the store but you
don't really smell much off an apple
until you actually take a bite
out of that apple and then you start
getting some of the uh aroma compounds
released and
so
we can actually
measure that and you see the instrument
that's used
on the on the right there it's a it's
our uh what we call the chore and and
here is a a
kind of a cartoon of how it works but
first it before we get back to the apple
if you look at the right hand side this
this chewer is actually used by a lot of
food development companies in this case
it's like the
beyond meat
where they they look at their uh
plant-based burger and compare the
texture to a meat-based
hamburger and so you simulate the the
chewing with this machine and it gives
you a
sense of the
texture so it's it's really pretty cool
i like those instruments because you can
actually
see what's going on unlike a
chromatograph you know you make an
injection and you know you don't see
anything
so
or
to the left of that you see the the sure
there so it's a a way of simulating the
uh the chewing but we can again take
that another step further by
putting that inside a
sample bag and so not only now are we
simulating the chewing and getting a
feel for the texture
but now we can capture
these flavor compounds as they are being
released while we are chewing so it's a
i guess they like the experience that
we're actually getting as we're eating
the food
and again we're trapping it on a speed
me unit and then analyzing it on the uh
on the gcms
so just to summarize the method here
again flavors are released during the
chewing process
and we can detect them subjectively by
the nodes but we can also uh measure
them objectively with the true brands so
compounds are collected by speedy and
then analyzed by
by gcms
but before we get to the to the flavor
so this is kind of interesting that you
can do
simultaneously look at the texture and
the flavor so on the top right where you
see the word brittle this actually
measures the texture so
there's
see you see there's five peaks so those
are five different chews off the apple
and that'll give you an idea of the the
crispiness or so if you will of the
apple and we'll see
the results on the on the next page
at the same time then we trap what is
being released in each of those choose
and then we'll do the the flavor
analysis by gcms and you see on the top
left
the red trace which is now the
after the the tube compared to what the
at the bottom is before the chewing
and you can see
uh big changes
in the size of the peak so these are the
compounds that are being released
during the the chewing
so
in this case again we're looking at
comparison of two species of apples and
so the the top one
because you can see the the peaks or the
i guess they are peaks they're larger so
that indicates that that apple is firmer
it's more crisp compared to the one on
the bottom that is more soft and chewy
so these are two different apples and we
can determine the the chewiness and how
firm the apple is
and then we trap the compounds
and so here we have the two different
apples so you have apple uh species not
a on the top
apple species
b
on the bottom and you can see that there
are some compounds
most of them are alcohol esters not
surprisingly
and some compounds if you look are
identical so that would be
the compounds that we would associate
with an apple flavor as opposed to a
pear flavor or a peach or any other
fruit so that's what we recognize as
apple
but there are also differences between
apple species a and b and that those are
the compounds that we would use to
differentiate between you know say a
golden delicious or a gala or fuji or
granny smith or any of these
apple species that we typically eat so
we can at a molecular level for after
the chewing collect these these
aroma compounds and then identify the
apple species just based
based on that
and that's that's all i had for today uh
i hope you you found it interesting
certainly the the chemistry
smell is very important you know we we
eat with our eyes as you know if you
look at the picture on the left there
with all the delicious food but we also
the the smell and the aroma of food is
also very important and so that
and being able to measure it is also
important especially
in the development of new foods so they
have kind of a consistent uh product
quality
so with with that i want to thank you uh
if you have any questions uh feel free
to email me at er [ __ ]
shimatsu.com i want to thank you for
listening to my presentation and
bon appetit